halsy reveals she suffered a miscarriage  twenty-one-year-old tells rolling stone  she got pregnant while touring last year  but before deciding what to do the  writer says Halsey found herself quote  screaming on a hotel bed  bloody naked from the waist down just  hours before she was set to perform  Halsey says she wanted to cancel the  show but was encouraged to take the  stage because it was Viva lyft and would  get three million impressions Halsey  reveals quote that was the moment of my  life where I thought to myself I don't  feel like a human being anymore she  explains it as the angriest performance  she's ever done in her life  but despite the loss huzi says she wants  kids in the future quote I want to be a  mom more than I want to be a pop star  more than I want to be anything in the  world